So how do we know that? Well, researchers gathered data from people who worked
closely with animals for a long period of time and particular species of
animals. Such as animal trainers, zoo keepers, and wildlife experts. The key
was that people had to be very familiar with many individuals of a certain
species, so they could rate unique behavioral tendencies, that is personality.
What they found was that members of the same species acted in unique ways over
a long period of time. That is they possess unique personality traits and
surprisingly the dimensions of personality that we use for humans is relatively
similar to those seen in animals. Let's look at this figure, here we see we
have ocean. So open this to experience, conscientiousness, extroversion,
agreeableness and neuroticism. Here we see that these animals have a unique
trait of openness so they vary in their openness to new experiences. We see
consciousness in chimpanzees and horses. So within these two species, there's a
variation of how conscientious different animals are. As for extroversion, we
see that nearly all of the animals, except the hyena, rat and chickadee show
variations in being extroverted. Similar to extroversion we see agreeableness
is seen in many animals, except for guppies, chickadees and octopus. And for
neurotocism, we see that many animals exhibit this feature, except for a few.